hello there reject nation the knights of
moons have occurred for the episode two
full-length watch-alongs
you're going to talk about remove that
with us over at our patreon page master
thanks to all become superior just for
checking out the content we've got offer
over there but if you can't share
support by our patreon sure support by
leaving a like that would mean a lot
subscribe click the notification bell to
get notified when our reaction for the
next episode of moon knight is up follow
this man koi zhangro on his youtube
channel but especially his tick tock
post theories and news all the time on
there it's great it's the best tik tok
i've ever seen also then boys at prepper
thanks for helping us edit down these
highlights tick tock tick tock let's go
[Music]
i can't tell the difference between my
waking life
graduate accents
i must warn you what you're about to see
is going to melt your brain
area 51 like
mi6 bonkers brother yeah
proof ready
yeah
it's like he wants to show it off
he's like proud in his own way wait for
it here it comes
no no no no wait
why are you going in what are you doing
you donut
just a minute
oh no
[Music]
[Laughter]
any museum property on your purse no i i
haven't i haven't nicked anything
that's why i have that
no nothing
oh
that's why i guess the job as a cabbie i
appreciate that
[Music]
that's a cool shot i like that a lot i
know you number 43 right i never forget
a face especially that handsome devil i
mean come on but i do forget an accent
i wonder if there's an easter egg if you
scan that qr oh
oh maybe an easter egg
all the rest of
[Music]
oh whoa
whoa
looks like a compass i need you to
listen to me very carefully oh
there he is here he comes
hello
i'm gonna go lay down on that [ __ ] back
there gonna take a nice nap oh god are
you joking sleep i'm never gonna go to
sleep again look i don't care how bloody
handsome you are
i serve can't you
i'm his avatar which means you are too
the egyptian god of the moon
oh my god that's the stupidest thing
which is a fragment of an underdone
potato i'm gonna go straight to the
authorities
and they're gonna put me away so i don't
hurt anyone else and hopefully
[Music]
take your key
who's the dominant body oh that was cool
all the shadows that's beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look upon me he is incredible
sorry i loved it
[Music]
oh
mark
where have you been
is this steven the latest fake identity
for you i figured that you're using
they're in love now it's not okay yeah
i'm still your wife
nice malware did you say wifi oh my are
we married she looks happy
no this is my mom's flat
marceline
you sent these papers but you never
signed them
did i uh this is what you wanted okay
everything you told me that we needed to
move on you've been served divorce
yeah are you doing this or not i don't
expect you to believe me i've stephen
listen to me honestly don't really
believe myself all i can do is try to
you're making a mistake
trying to show you what i found yeah
it's kind of like the movie ghost in
some ways
stop what you're doing right now all
sorts of get away from the bag don't
show her what's in the bag
you're going to get her killed you hear
me
now you're done i'm steven grant i work
in a gift shop and i think i'm in real
danger and i think maybe that you might
be the only person that can help me oh
softy hello officers how are you stephen
graham anyone else here with you
uh here with me no um
what's this
it's a paperweight
where'd you get a paperweight shop with
some infinity stones around it
you're in possession of a stolen item no
no i don't i don't have it
but don't
no it's not here
awkward fella looks just like you
fake passport and a thief you just come
with us son
you're no mama man
so who are these guys i assume they are
going to be working for another god or
ethan hawk hydra got it okay hydro the
hydra
see if he's got the merc now why would
you tell oh yeah
mark specter versus religion is that
what you think i'm
i am
never
giving you control again do you hear me
i hear you loud and clear
i'm curious do you think that
can't you chose you as
his avatar because your mind would be so
easy to break or because it was broken
already good question yes before you get
excited put on the cape
i'd love to take this opportunity to
show you around
oh
people don't want to hear good news
they'd rather cling to their fear cling
to their pain
reaction channel
to dolphins
colt reacts i was the fist of vengeance
can't you
punishes those who have already walked
an evil path his retribution comes too
late by the time his
fist of vengeance arrives people have
already suffered
i get it right i wonder if this shoes is
a retribution for his time with konchi
reason isn't that a bit dodgy like
trusting the judgment of a weird
crocodile lady
light the path to good by eradicating
the choice of evil which
brings us
to the scarab dude she's like a pre-cog
minority reports happen though functions
as a kind of compass
leading us to ahmed's tomb evil
eradicated stephen
ah he is persuasive do not give layla
just give me the body give it a bite
give me the body
just give me the body
this is
ahmed's gift
to her first avatar contains in a tiny
sliver of her power i don't want to use
it men don't
where is the scarer i have it
[Music]
and keep this safe
[Laughter]
oh
that is some power purple mcu purple
oh boy
here we
go the drag me to hell vibe right there
oh my god
i'm going to die an evil magician's man
cave
[Laughter]
you can do this i promise kiss him
another way
throw him out the window
[Music]
oh
[Music]
mr knight already nice superhero landing
i don't know she said i needed a suit
yeah the ceremonial armor from conscious
temple not psycho colonel sanders
[Laughter]
where is guy this guy was oh um
yes
great use of character based humor too
yeah
oh neat
stay away from me
so i imagine you have to believe to see
it to a certain level maybe like it's a
gift seeing is believing
ouch
they really saved a lot of this fight
scene wow that's so crazy you can't
handle this
yeah
i never thought the roll-up sleeves were
used comedically this is amazing
oh
ow
it looks like a comic book panel
all right do it take control
for now
in his eyes too
[Music]
yes
oh
get to the moon
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
yes
money shot
this feels like a genuinely great 90s
movie yeah
yeah like a good one
fun in the right ways
like the supernatural horror action
movie yeah like an instant cult classic
of those movies yeah yeah disturb man
it belongs to me
i can offer you food
clothing
but i am unable to offer you this thank
you
i should live to see the world we make
but i've decided you're a bad guy you're
judgmental
jerk he doesn't want to serve the god he
wants to become the god uh
this is what it's like
being on the inside oh interesting i
don't trust anything you say you hurt
people hitting him i'm never gonna let
you hurt anyone else ever again shut
up it gives you a moment
whoa
[Music]
[Laughter]
you
were nothing more than a corpse when i
found you you think
you owned this body
[Music]
may not like my next candidate
near and dear as she is to you where are
we going
where the hell do you think see ya egypt
[Music]
marvel body shot let's see it we're
going to the liquor store oscar isaac's
like ah i'm in shape enough
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
aaron and justin
so there is no opening credits other
it's just the marvel fanfare there's not
like title sequence
lets the show speak for itself
i think it's the first one to do that i
think
that before they shot anything they got
in a room and said
yeah before we write this first episode
let's make a shot list of how many cool
symbolic mirror moments we could have
let's put each amount per episode
they're like we had a spread of six we
have 60 shots let's do like 10 an
episode from here on
the the most frequent note was just can
we get more mirrors in here can we have
more reflective surfaces it's got more
mirrors that have more and more cracks
on this one yeah it's you know his inner
turmoil
it's sternalized through the range
he himself is breaking from
that crack in his psyche in this movie i
mean it's always beautiful to look at as
much as i'm making a sarcastic little
just it's always beautiful look what a
show amazing and it's always used at the
appropriate moments i love the way they
like locked off the camera when he's
kicking the pyramid there like you just
get every impact of
the force of his anguish because like
he's kicking himself in a way so it's
like you get the feeling of you and the
pov of being kicked absolutely i've also
definitely met ethan hawk's character
that's definitely he's doing such a good
job with that like cult leader since
what the hell are you getting at here
mccoy just said he was part of a call
protagonist yeah he's the good guy cults
are good postcard at scene credits
that's my post credit scene
look at all the straight face
[Laughter]
we had it yeah you guys
immediately
i was like i can't believe i brought
this joke right now because that's the
joke we need to bring back that is the
joke
commitment the co-producer son danielle
iman holding it down oh sarah haley finn
is a consulting producer on this one
she's a casting director that's
interesting i'm glad they gave her more
power she's really helped shape this
universe she should get more credit
said design
oh wow
there were vfx in the show ah that was
all practical
everyone who worked on the mirror
they're a mirror
mirror wrangler fabricator
behind the scenes you're going to see
like a bunch of grips of
prop people being like we use like 48
mirrors per episode
we actually have the actors stand to the
left of cameron we shoot into a mirror
to catch the performer that's actually
oscar isaac's face the other way yeah
the reason it looks strange everything's
flipped in the show what
i'm still going with this this credits
joke i'm i'm here
you said you sound really over it oh
yeah now we're here we've got to commit
to it we haven't even gotten to the let
me see there's a post credit scene i
want to see who dubbed this in brazil
mirrorist yes
good job's important
yes
[Music]
this is a choice
this is truly a choice
it's worth the hour
just play credits
i'm gonna talk about it just take credit
the credits it should be the end of all
our videos oh us watching the credits
that's the reaction
encourage more people to appreciate all
the people the time and efforts
i ignore my mental health
you see people say mental health and
that always sounds negative it's like
you say that's all it's like that's
something that needs to be worked on
okay just mental state is it healthy is
it not healthy
but physical state is it healthy is it
not wouldn't you say your mental health
does always need to be worked on of
course that's not one of those i'm
saying there's only nine times that time
when someone says mental health oh it's
going to kind of associate yeah the
connotation is you need to work on your
problem
right right as opposed to your mental
health should always be addressed mental
health should just be a category of like
health is it healthy you're not healthy
well you know here in america we're just
learning about mental health so
obviously we're only going to talk about
it when it's a problem i don't need to
worry just looking into it my mental
state is at a great health always always
at a healthy all-time high
all right guys let's review this let's
all right i like i liked the order last
time
please
take over my body
i i'm just uh dazzled i'm really
enjoying the evolution of this show and
i appreciate it in this episode how much
they really clung to and
drove home i feel like there could have
been too much of the stephen
and mark debate but i really love how
throughout this episode you have that at
play as the end comes up steven actually
gets a few licks in he's kind of feeling
it he's coming around to the life that
he has been plopped into but then
ultimately does give over control to
mark and it's the beginning of what i
would imagine could be some kind of
interplay that's a little more amicable
between the two or at least a little
more lucid between the two just even
more of that dynamic between him and
ethan hawke from the last episode of
this episode like i really cannot say
enough about just how much i'm enjoying
this thus far and two i mean
what uh crap i'm blanking on her name
but you know the the addition of of
layla there you go
uh you know he reads the comments i mean
honestly expert writes the comics
i didn't ask about it
i'm just gonna go on record right now
like a john episode five he's like i'm
not the one
just take the body guys
put me in the reflection and i'll just
be quiet
but no comic john doesn't have a
mustache i just picture like comment
shots the exact same but like
mustacheless
and then i got white chaps on it
that's nice that's my outfit and a big
whip
uh but yeah no no i i like how this is
sort of gradually growing and you get
that pitch of fight club meets indiana
jones and you know i feel like it's
getting to that but it's taking its time
it's growing gradually it's doing that
with a lot of thrilling and tense action
and stuff like that and one thing that
struck me in this episode was out of a
lot of the marvel stuff this has a
better grasp on humor
circa character perspective rather than
let's pepper in a joke that someone
wrote as punch up or something like that
like you said that 90s action fantasy
horror vibe where yeah it's he's a fish
out of water so of course there's gonna
be some humor that comes with that and i
appreciate that that levity is able to
balance off against what could
potentially be one of the more cultish
sort of darker corners of the mcu thus
far
so i think the end of days flavor really
works for this and i wouldn't have
expected that if you told me it was a
90s horror thriller type show i've been
like that's like what you you clarified
twice because for some reason that
connotation is like a demerit but in
this case it's really not like it's a
very positive thing it's like when you
watch one of those from the knives
you're like that's it's good yeah you go
back to like dark city it's great
so like spawn director's cut isn't as
bad as the actual
yeah but like the faculty final
destination like there's there's a great
genre
yeah i mean yeah but i i think that
really works with what you're saying
with the humor sensibilities is that
since moonlight is a funny character but
he's not spider-man moon knight is a
funny character but he's not shield
there's different types of humor to make
these characters work and this one does
feel very authentic to not only the show
but to what i sense of the character and
it doesn't feel like it's like oh it's
been dark for a while make a joke it's
this is something this character would
actually do i never would have imagined
mr knight this early nor would i have
imagined mr knight rolling up his
sleeves to be for a comedic effect
because when we all saw that mr that
poster where the sleaze rolled up we
were like oh badass and then they used
it comedically and it worked really well
so i i really enjoy the fact that that
costume
could be
the badass suit or it could be what
happened where it's like i need a suit
like it's in universe humor that's
landing really well to me so far the
moments between stephen and mark are in
this episode the most accurate how the
comic felt to me but like the scenes of
them talking and interacting and
fighting for control there was a few
moments where like i could almost see
the square panels not speech bubble
panels but the square panels that moon
knight uses to like keep everything
going the narration panels yeah so i
felt narration panels happening in real
time and this episode maybe more than
the first one felt like a comic the
sweeping shot where konchu moved three
times felt like a pop pop pop panel from
a book where it'd be like he's hearing
series here like it's
it's overused it's a trope but like a
comic come to life in so many ways like
it's so pretty a living comedy a living
comedy i've been the immortal words of
joel schumacher it's very good
it might it might overtake loki if it
gets sticks and landing i'm gonna say it
again
what do you got
for the third portion we both have to do
the slow oh okay
which is going
i'm not a fan anymore this is uh
all trash
your friends directed this yeah i'm like
so proud of my crap directly i'm gonna
tell you i'm just saying crap utter crap
yes suck
no this is this is some of my favorite
uh so far i love how it's not even
acknowledged the mcu like it hasn't even
done any of that right which for some
people automatically means it's good
for
me i think it's cool because it really
makes it its own thing like we've talked
a lot about different genres that it's
sort of implemented here throughout i
was even getting vibes of like the movie
ghost in a lot of ways you know like
having that you've seen ghosts right
we'll be using ghosts yeah
[Laughter]
but there are elements of ghosts in here
you know i think i think with the think
about what do you mean sure watch me i'm
agree with you watch me go all right i
think there's shades of it there are
shades of like with layla and steven
that kind of remind me of like whoopi
trying to communicate with demi and then
also with like stephen going around but
he's got like a ghost following him
around telling him what to do as well
has that vibe but i think also even with
mr knight they implemented like a tone
and genre style that i just didn't
expect it felt something almost akin to
like a fred astaire movie in some ways i
loved how in that fight the way he is
with his kind of suit and the way he
moves around kind of like a dance out of
like a 30s movie then when he's they're
fighting the jackal the both of them the
fact that they chose not to show the
jackal it was working on so many levels
for me like it was like watching the
because the suit kind of reminds me like
the invisible man for some reason and
then you're watching the invisible man
fight something invisible
and then the way they're moving around
fighting it you're just watching the
choreography of the stunt work it really
gets the shine word usually if you can
see the jackal yeah you're trying to
find them you're distracted by the
visuals around you and it made it work
much stronger you're also seeing it
through the perspective of how everyone
else is seeing with like this weird
chaos of like this is just a crazy man
right this dude belongs in the loon bin
you know i kind of vibe about it i
thought it was really strong and the the
layla relationship i i became more
interested in her
when she showed up and was
ash and i really like the way stephen
grant the way stephen grant has an
affinity towards her is what was maybe
lacking in the marriage between mark
spector and her yeah you know
yeah
and so i liked having that extra layer
to establish with like oh maybe she
might fall in love with steven you know
i've also enjoyed that mark's like not
the greatest because like in the comic
books mark spectre is kind of a dick
because moon knight can be kind of a
dick so it was nice
yeah like that guy
he owes me money so i'm enjoying that we
have a very likable
protagonist and an unlikable protagonist
as one protagonist because like i see
the need for mark but he's a swiss army
knife so far i'm not like oh i'm
supporting mark like i don't trust mark
spectre and i like that because i'm
rooting for
our more squirrely guy because of how
endearing he is whereas mark i was
afraid would be more interesting and i'd
be less interested in steven and i'm not
yet they both serve a different like
narrative purpose and i was also telling
john before i really like that this show
as you said isn't connected to the mcu
because a lot of times like once the
comic gets into the hundreds people are
like oh i can't jump on it's too
intimidating it's a new arc you could
show this to someone that's never seen a
marvel movie and it's an abuser you
really can people say that all the time
about like every marvel property now but
this one this one you really
i've watched a few marvels with my
family and that is often a distinct
barrier and this is a show i've been
sitting here going i could easily put
this on and everyone would have fine
time just like they did with loki yeah
and loki's got even way more of that
sort of like oh the marvel universe but
but it's doing it in a madcap way
whereas this is just very much focused
on what it is and what it's doing yeah
it's of like that mummy returns
absolutely like mommy returns more than
mommy i would say yeah
yeah yeah i said at the top before the
credits even happened that like this
reminded me of justin aaron's work
before i knew this was one of their
episodes because it's half muhammad i
believe his name uh and then half justin
aaron and i
could tell some of their shots but it
worked so well for this universe that
it's kind of like what i wanted a
igrad's ant-man like
a stylized choice in the marvel universe
this felt like one of their movies while
still working because marvel let them
and it still also feels like the first
episode like the tonalities totally play
here for their universe and i'm excited
for their loki no even more their thing
that they directed before was like uh
times
yeah yeah yeah they did uncut gems yeah
yeah yep you really get that kind of
like paranoia
everyone was really surprised
yeah angry at each other i didn't think
i'd like sandler's computer's voice for
work
yeah i'm cautious
i really also it's it's just a tiny
little moment but i really love when
leila
we're gonna film the third one today i
can tell
sorry we're gonna do it all in the chat
right now
it's all good
it was a tiny tiny tiny little thing but
i really it really struck me when layla
calls him stephen for the first time
she's accepting him yeah yeah yeah i
love to that that that how hard they
make it because he doesn't understand
what's happening to him and i like that
it's really hard for him to get across
what he's going through without being
like i don't i think i have a split
personality like i believe the struggle
in his being like so overwhelmed and
perplexed trying to communicate what is
happening clearly you know the interplay
of like okay mark just keep making
whatever weird choice you want to make
and then finally it comes around to like
okay maybe this is
more than i
bargained for more than i gave it credit
for or something like that i also really
liked that i was reluctant for mark to
take over every time then at the end
when mark did it felt like the villain
when winning a little bit like when we
lost steven to him i really liked it i
was like no no no no we need the guy
that's like lesson control back we also
see why we need mark and i love that
last shot in egypt that to me with him
sitting with the drink
looked like mark spector like it was
cool to see like that's the comic to me
well it makes me wonder that if the
third episode is gonna dive heavily into
we're gonna do much more mark specter's
perspective
in egypt and things like that you know
and it's gonna be like leaving off here
i really liked that you know he takes
hold and those last final moments do
give you a sense for him as a person it
felt like a strong character
introduction so that now next time yeah
we can really dive in and learn who he
is and then have two fully formed
characters in one body yeah and that's
some [ __ ] acting man we said it in
the last episode but oscar isaac every
his eyes like there's so many moments
ross talk in that argue which is all
editing but still like is so good like
and i know that the people some people
have problem with the accent i love it
because it distinguishes them so
completely that they're literally in the
same outfit so it'd be really
distracting if they sounded the same and
you also don't want something that's
like
too similar and you you have such a
dichotomy between these two characters
it is two separate performances down to
the mannerisms down like there's just so
much
i don't know
i think
i have a minnesota accent
can one of them have a mullet i think so
i agree well i think you guys touched on
two points of what is
how you talk about his perplexity and
the complexity of his situations is that
is first and foremost in scenes that
often present humor because part of a
lot of the humor that came out of this
one is oh it's a fish out of water story
something that i didn't actually
anticipate even though the trailers
really cleared him the first episode did
but i'm like oh wait a minute yeah this
is like the breaking act two fun and
games this is the fish out of water tail
here and even in the scene with arthur
when he's at is like little all the
zealots and stuff the humor that comes
through there
does not feel like primary
it doesn't feel like
who talks first do i talk first huh
star wars oscar isaac
doesn't feel like this joke come from
right and like we're going to eat the
funny right now they fly now
classic oscars
how good the script is is a testament to
them getting oscar isaac back because he
was like you guys screwed me with this
in the same studio in the same thing so
i see why he signed on for this because
we all talked like i can't believe he's
back to doing franchise anything with
disney and this is the opposite they're
letting him go well i think the way that
you work with the humor and i think what
they've done narratively with mark
spector because
john if i'm not mistaken yeah yeah i'm
listening sorry i i need you to check
you don't worry don't worry
in the moonlight comments uh-huh yeah
it's usually mark spector is the
protagonist that you're following yes
that is you are correct god yeah only
your reputation is intact i really read
a sentence and i try to retain it and
the sentence was mark spectre
no what i'm saying is that what you were
talking about with mark spector of like
you feel like he's not really a good guy
and they're leaning into that they've
done this cool narrative trick where
they'd switch the perspectives they
switch to the primary person as you're
gonna be following the protagonist so to
speak and
they're doing that thing with the
supporting character mark spector
where
he is like the tough guy [ __ ] but you
know there's a good guy
yeah we'll uncover him yeah well that's
covered on moonlight and
he is slowly going to be showing that's
because he's like the closed off like
the wolverine british batman ish uh kind
of guy but you know he has the
quote-unquote save the cat quality about
him because he literally saves our
protagonist
yeah
yeah stephen's again he's like saving
our protagonists and also made maybe do
these experiences i was asking like what
will the arc of this show be and as i'm
watching this it's like okay it looks
like mark is gonna have to learn to be a
bit more vulnerable
and stephen is gonna have to learn to
quit being such a
a wimp in a lot of situations you know
like he's not a wimp but he's learning
to stand up for himself to fight back do
you know and i think that's what makes
you root for him so much and i do like
the idea of having one character have to
go two different directions in his own
arc i like that
yeah they're gonna learn from each other
yeah and then in the third act we get a
cabbie they don't know the best of both
worlds i know what they're going to do
they're going to stand in front of a
clean
unbroken mirror it's just going to be a
one great big miracle not a crack in
there beautiful lighting it's going to
be amazing very excited from domestics
and then layla is totally karen allen
what's her name yeah oh
indiana jones yeah yeah yeah john you're
harry comics
or marrying crane marion crane that's
what it
is has a rachel nice look about her
which is funny you mentioned the mummy
like she's got that like bad ass rachel
i thought it was smart is that she
actually kind of looks like the person
stephen was going to take on a date with
yes that was i thought it was her first
yeah yeah i like that he's got a type
even though he doesn't know a
subconscious has a type like he
literally has other side both of them
like this type of well it seems like
mark here's here's what i'm getting from
the relationship mark is an [ __ ]
mm-hmm that's all i got now mark is an
[ __ ]
and it seems like the steven personality
is all derived from the good that he
sees within layla oh yeah i mean if
you're looking at like
oh all the french poems like mark you
don't like that [ __ ] you know you read
this flowery crap always watching
football and and cleaning picking your
butt you know that's what you're doing
all the time
that's a really good night i like the
french uh where he he's trying to form
this this positive self perhaps say
hieroglyphics the obsession with the
egyptian stuff i like that it's good
note yeah i don't think it's a note i
think it's right there well excuse me
so clear things he loves and can't you
it's gonna be like on my planet i am
considering
you
well i think it was so cool how how uh
arthur harrow knew so much about what
was going on i loved how he was doing
like a play-by-play too of what was
happening like what kanchu was probably
saying like this is all predictable you
don't need to trust him i know better
but it seems like they've really
established that this guy has no
interest in serving some higher god yeah
i like him
by himself for that show that's like hey
he's not in it for actually even in his
mind the selfless reasons like he wants
to be the judge
although i did like it a little bit more
when he was doing it for to sort of like
i like the idea of like two gods
battling it out like
systems i think
i'm waiting to see how they'll elaborate
on that note because yeah that last beat
where it's clear like oh no like there's
something interesting about having him
be you know as he is presented yeah
servant a leader somebody who is
compassionate for the people that he at
least has seen to be worthy and good and
blah blah but then yeah to see that
moment pass in this you know this
homeless guy who didn't deserve to be
wasted
you know and he didn't even well and he
doesn't even do did not weigh him
on the scales man and so yeah that's
like an
overtly
villainous deed you don't see the
compassion and the compassion was
interesting yeah that's the one thing
that i am curious to see go forward as i
was sitting here admiring this going wow
i especially when he does the
play-by-play i'm like oh this is a nice
subversion because you know they're
already at odds but to have him be like
no i know what you're going through and
and i can also make this seem even more
like a psychosis you're experiencing or
something and also being a former moon
knight yeah absolutely uh i thought that
was quite compelling and you know i'm
sure that will still hold in the
dynamics when he meets with stephen and
mark and all that but yeah having that
extra look behind the curtain of what
the rest of the characters don't really
know yet is yeah i'm curious to see if
they'll still be able to keep the
character of arthur feeling as rich and
interesting as a villain or if he will
sort of start to slope into you know i
just want to be a god
you know can't wait for midnight sons
this there's so much ghost rider that
like pulls from this kind of mythology
that this because of this you can get
ghost rider to feel very natural in the
mcu as much as this is removed from the
mcu it really allows for an entire new
corner like guardians did you like
conscious head on fire you're halfway
there there it is boom you're like your
skull's on fire but i'm good
he's trying to you know get that
marvel r-rated supernatural door open i
mean it worked this was like let's just
not acknowledge mcu in this one yeah
i wonder if it ever will like if we get
to episode six and there's any like how
balls
that's what would make it more rewarding
when he does crossover with someone yeah
that because of the fact that none of it
was ever mentioned before and in the
books like whenever he's there it's like
oh shit's getting real move nights here
there's been times he's teamed up but
that was all in his head they didn't
team up with anyone yeah so is that
right john
you are
well
don't even sweating that was the second
sentence and then moon night it wasn't
advanced but it would be so cool
it would be so cool to have a character
who you never know when they'll show up
in the greater universe and when they do
it does come with that like oh dang yeah
like there's a tone shift happening
right right like another presentation i
think these are two of the best outfits
i've ever seen in marvel mm-hmm
the mr knight and the moon knight i
think they're both phenomenal yeah and i
love the cape and i i can see where it's
sometimes see drive it it really makes
the imagery of a cape sing and it's not
easy to have a cape like in in a in a in
a universe that's grounded they're it's
a cake i mean there's shots where it's
definitely practical no yeah but it's
like running on rooftops and stuff in
london you know it's definitely cgi it's
just cool to get like the cgi it's those
parts of it feel like a little bit of
american werewolf in london too i like
that yeah oh yeah yeah good call there's
a lot of things here your friends gonna
watch us i feel like we said a lot of
good things hey we like your work and
they have those things i'm sure they
have plenty of time to watch i'll take
one through their good job on good time
and uncut
yeah
in real life watch spring in the endless
dust and hair are incredible yeah oh the
ones from the safety brothers yeah
absolutely yeah
so they're going to watch this the
sci-fi 70s
just tell them to watch the review i've
said a lot of positive things just i'll
make sure they see that this part though
that you asked i can make a uh cut down
of just what i said just break
we're not even here yeah i'm gonna make
sure they know that you read this drop
it on my face just begin praising them
and then work with robert pence
my own super cut of just people checking
with me to make sure the comic book
references
so that i can remember this one day the
rest of my life send that to everyone in
town that you're the comic book this
will be my new showdown free for all the
one day
the one time roast to the occasion
all right guys all right
don't show your friends as part of the
video tell them when it gets to 24
minutes to fast forward
two times once you hit 24 minutes make
sure to fast forward a little bit yeah
we're done
another no no no we'll we'll look very
different next time you see us
i'll have a beard
it's not trucking you better now it's on
sits on the ratchet
[Music]
you